GENERATION WITH STUDENT DEBT.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP.
A SYSTEM WIDE MELTDOWN AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS REAL.
THAT ACCORDING TO SENIOR DHS
OFFICIALS.
SOUNDING THE ALARM ABOUT THE
REAL CRISIS SPIRALAG OUT OF
CONTROL.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS SURGING.
BORDER PATROL IS EXPECTED TO
MAKE 100,000 APPREHENSION THIS
IS MONTH ALONE.
THE MAJORITY TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
ARE FAMILY UNIT WITH MINORS.
ONE SENIOR OFFICIAL TOLD FOX
NEWS THAT THE VOLUME OF MIGRANTS
IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
MAJOR PORTS OF ENTRY FACE
SERIOUS BACKLOGS.
TRUCKS DELIVERING CARGO WAIT
AROUND TO BE PROCESSED.
U.S. BORDER PERSONNEL ARE
OVERWHELMED.
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS ARE PUTTING US
IN MORE DANGER.
IT'S ABOUT TO GET WORSE.
ANOTHER MASSIVE MIGRANTS CARAVAN
IS ON THE WAY.
THE PRESIDENT MAY HAVE TO CLOSE
DOWN THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MEXICO.
I WANTED TO CLOSE IT.
MEXICO SAID NO, NO, NO.
FIRST TIME IN DECADES.
WE WON'T LET ANYBODY GET
THROUGH.
THEY APPREHENDED OVER 1,000
PEOPLE TODAY AT THEIR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
BUT THEY DON'T WANT THE BORDER
CLOSED.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE DOESN'T WANT
THE BORDER CLOSED?
THE DEMOCRATS.
I AGREE, BUT TRADE AND COMMERCE
AND MAKING MONEY IS IMPORTANT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT JOB I HAVE IS
THE SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
OTHER THINGS I TALKED ABOUT.
>> Sean: IT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT
CUT OFF U.S. AID TO 3 COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE RAISED SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS REAL CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
FOR GOOD REASON.
WE HAVE SEEN THE IMANS.
-- IMAGES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
DEMANDING AGREE INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVE SEEN THE DATA AND
REPEATED IT OFTEN INCLUDING THE
DEVASTATION FROM HEROIN.
90% OF THAT DRUG POURS ACROSS
THAT SOUTHERN BORDER NEVER MIND
FENTANYL.
WE HEARD FROM BORDER PATROL
PERSONNEL.
THEY ARE ASKING FOR HELP.
ASKING FOR WALLS AND MORE AGENTS
AND MORE SECURITY EQUIPMENT.
EVEN THE BORDER PATROL CHIEF
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA IS SAYING
THIS A REAL EMERGENCY.
REMEMBER WHEN THE PRESS ARM OF
THE EXTREME RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY USING THE SAME
PHRASE.
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
THEY CAN'T SEPARATE THEMSELVES
BY PICKING DIFFERENT WORDS.
WATCH THIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST STOP
HOLDING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HOSTAGE AND MANUFACTURING A
CRISIS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT MANUFACTURED A
>> THE BIG SCAM OF THE WHOLE
ADDRESS IS THERE A CRISIS.
THERE IS NOT A CRISIS.
>> THE LOCALS WOULD TELL HIM ON
THE BORDER EVEN CONSERVATIVES
THERE IS NOT A NATIONAL SECURITY
PROCESS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS MANUFACTURING
A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
>> THE NOTION WE HAVE A CRISIS
THERE IS NONSENSE.
>> SOME QUESTION IF THERE IS A
CRISIS AT ALL.
>> THERE IS NOT A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
IT'S A MANUFACTURED CRISIS FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO GET A POLITICAL
WIN.
>> THIS ARTIFICIAL CRISIS OF THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T JUSTIFY MONEY
FOR A QUAL.
>> IS THERE A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER?
THE PRESIDENT SAID THERE IS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> DRUG CARTELS AND GANGS AND
4,000 PLUS HOMICIDE.
30,000 SEXUAL ASSAULTS AND
100,000 VIOLENT ASSAULTS BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE 2%.
ALWAYS THE SAME PEOPLE SPREADING
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
FOR 2 YEARS ON COLLUSION.
THEIR HATRED FOR TRUMP OVERRIDES
ANY COMMON SENSE OR EVEN A REAL
NATIONAL SECURITY, HUMANITARIAN
EMERGENCY AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
REMEMBER, THESE COUNTRIES,
PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS WALL
BEING BUILT.
THEY ARE SEEING THIS AS A LAST
OPPORTUNITY TO GET INTO AMERICA
ILLEGALLY.
WE SENT OUR FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
LAWRENCE JONES DOWN TO THE
BORDER STATE OF TEXAS TO SEE
WHAT THEY THINK OF THE ON-GOING
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BETO O'ROURKE IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE ALREADY SHAKING YOUR
HEAD.
HE SAID WE SHOULD TEAR THE WALL
DOWN AND WE ALREADY HAVE.
>> NO.
>> YOU DON'T FEEL THAT IS
REASONABLE?
>> NOT AT ALL.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE WALLS UP.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO COME HERE,
THEY CAN COME LEGALLY.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A HUGE
MISTAKE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE BORDERS.
WE HAVE TO ENFORCE THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
>> I DO BELIEVE THEY SHOULD DO
THE WALLS.
>> LEAVE THE FENCING.
I DON'T FEEL WE NEED TO BUILD
THE WALL.
>> WE PUT BORDERS UP TO SECURE
THE COUNTRY AND TEXAS AND THE
SOVEREIGNTY.
THE BORDER IS THERE FOR A
REASON.
>> I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
I THINK THE WALL [INAUDIBLE].
>> HOW DO YOU STOP THEM FROM
CROSSING OVER?
>> HMMM.
I AM CERTAIN THERE IS TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS BETTER THAN A WALL.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE THERE IS A
CURRENT CRISIS WHERE THE BORDER?
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> THEY THAT WILL BE NAIVE TO
SAY THERE IS NO ISSUE.
>> THE BORDERS ARE OVERWHELMED.
IT'S OVER-TAXING THE CITIZENS OF
TEXAS AND OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID IF THEY
DON'T GET IT TOGETHER, THEN HE
WILL SHUTDOWN THE ENTIRE BORDER.
WHAT SAY YOU TO THAT?
>> IT SOUNDS EXTREME.
IF IT NEEDS TO BE DONE, LET'S DO
IT.
LET'S DO IT.
>> Sean: WE WILL TRACK THE
EMERGENCY AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
CLOSELY AND SHOW WHAT YOU OTHER
NETWORKS WILL NOT ACTUALLY
REPORT:
FACTS.
THAT'S COMING UP TOMORROW.
LAWRENCE WILL BE WITH THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN TEXAS WITH A
SPECIAL SEGMENT.
FIRST OUR IMPORTANT "HANNITY"
WATCH ON THE DEMOCRATIC 2020
CANDIDATES.
TWO MORE WOMEN HAVE COME FORWARD
TO ACCUSE CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE
BIDEN OF INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT.
ONE CLAIMS THAT BIDEN RESTED HER
HAND ON HER THIGH AS SHE SKIRMED
IN HER SHEET.
UNCLE JOE IS NOT HAPPY THAT HIS
PUBLIC DISPLAY OF AFFECTION IS A
BIG ISSUE IN THE CAMPAIGN.
INSTEAD OF OWNING UP TO HIS
CREEP BEHAVIOR AND APOLOGIZING.
BIDEN'S CAMP IS BLAMING
EVERYBODY INCLUDING BERNIE
SANDERS'S CAMPAIGN.
A PICTURE LIKE THAT AND OTHERS
SPEAK THOUSANDS OF WORDS ON
THEIR OWN.
THESE IMAGES DO NOT LOOK GO.
THE SANDERS CAMPAIGN DENIED THEY
PLANTED THE STORY.
WASN'T IT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT TOLD US TO BELIEVE ALL
WOMEN?
NO DUE PROCESS.
ANYONE ACCUSED SHOULD SIT DOWN
AND SHUT UP.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> I BELIEVE HER.
FIRST OF ALL.
ANYBODY WHO COMES FORWARD AT
THIS POINT TO BE PREPARED TO
TESTIFY IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE AGAINST SOMEONE WHO IS
BEING NOMINATED TO ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL POSITIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT, THAT
TAKES AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
COVERAGE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE DOCTOR
FORD WHO COME FORWARD NEED TO BE
HEARD, BUT THEY NEED TO BE
BELIEVED.
>> THE MEN IN THIS COUNTRY, JUST
SHUT UP AND ZIP UP.
DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> LET ME SAY I BELIEVE
DR. FORD.
I BELIEVE THE SURVIVOR HERE.
>> I BELIEVE HER.
I STAND WITH HER.
>> Sean: I BELIEVE, I BELIEVE, I
BELIEVE.
I GUESS THAT DOESN'T APPLY TO
THE WOMEN THAT ARE ACCUSING
BIDEN OF HARASKING ALLEGEDLY AND
ANY ACCOUNT DEMOCRAT.
DO THEY BELIEVE THE WOMEN THAT
HAVE BEEN ACCUSING THE VIRGINIA
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR FAIRFAX
FACING TWO ALLEGATIONS OF
VIOLENT SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RAPE.
WHY ARE ALL OF THE I BELIEVE
WOMEN PEOPLE?
ARE THEY PROTESTING IN THE
STREETS OF RICHMOND?
DEMANDED HIS FIRING OR A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION?
NOPE.
VIRGINIA DEMOCRATS WON'T EVEN
HOLD A BIPARTISAN HEARING FOR
THE ACCUSERS.
NOW THESE TWO WOMEN ARE SPEAKING
OUT IN POWERFUL INTERVIEWS.
LAST NIGHT WE SHOWED YOU THIS
CLIP FROM VANESSA TYSON.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE WAS PUSHING DOWN AND
PUSHING DOWN.
I COULD NOT HOLD MY NECK UP.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
[CRYING].
I HONESTLY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
THE NEXT THING I KNOW, MY LEAD
IS LITERALLY IN HIS CROTCH.
>> THE SEXUAL ASSAULT IS AN
EPIDEMIC TAKING PLACE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT TO HAPPEN TO
FAIRFAX?
>> I WANT HIM TO RESIGN.
>> Sean: TODAY THE SECOND
ACCUSER ALSO SPEAKING OUT
TELLING GAIL KING HOW FAIRFAX
RAPED HER AT DUKE UNIVERSITY.
>> HE DID THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT DO TO SOMEONE.
WITHOUT THEIR PERMISSION.
I TRIED SEVERAL TIMES TO GET UP
AND LEAVE.
I WAS PUSHED BACK DOWN.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> HMMM, HE SEXUAL ASSAULTED AND
RAPED ME.
>> YOU MADE IT CLEAR THIS IS NOT
WHAT I WANT?
>> IT WAS VERY CLEAR.
>> YOU KNOW HE IS SAYING THIS
NIGHT WAS CONSENSUAL?
>> IF YOU HAVE TO HOLD SOMEONE
DOWN, IT'S NOT CONSENSUAL.
>> Sean: BOTH WOMEN TELLING
PEOPLE AT THE TIME.
THE SILENCE IS DEAFENING.
HE CALLS THE INCIDENTS
CONSENSUAL.
IN THIS PROGRAM WE BELIEVE IN
DUE PROCESS BUT WE TAKE THESE
ALLEGATIONS VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE COMMEND GALE KING FOR DOING
THE SAME AND THE  THEY TREATED
IT WITH SERIOUSNESS AND GAVE A
RESPONSE FOR JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IGNORED
THOSE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FAKE NEWS CNN AND MSNBC AND
OTHERS IGNORING REAL SCANDALS
AND REAL STORIES AND REAL
EVIDENCE ABOUT THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTING THE
OPPOSITE AS THEY WOULD IF THIS
WAS A REPUBLICAN.
INSTEAD THEY SPENT YEARS PUSHING
COLLUSION, COLLUSION.
WITH NO EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP
AND IGNORING THE BIGGEST ABUSE
OF POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
HISTORY.
THIS MEDIA MOB IS PREPARED TO
GIVE ANY DEMOCRAT A FREE PASS.
WE WILL SEE THIS PLAY OUT IN
REAL TIME.
WHERE ARE ALL OF YOU "I
BELIEVE"ERS?
ELIZABETH WARREN, SHE IS FACING
ZERO BLOW BACK FOR CALLING THE
PRESIDENT A WALKING AND TALKING
THREAT TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
SHE CAN SAY ANYTHING SHE WANTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AT LEAST 25 PEOPLE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN DENIED
SECURITY CLEARANCES.
YEAH?
BECAUSE THEY HAD TIES TO FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
BECAUSE THEY HAD CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST.
BECAUSE THEY HAD FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES DO?
INSTEAD OF SAYING, HEY, WHOA, MY
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO WATCH OUT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
NO.
THESE ARE FRIENDS.
PEOPLE WITH MONEY AND WITH
CONNECTIONS.
THE ANSWER WAS, JUST RAM THEM ON
THROUGH.
YOU KNOW, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS A WALKING,
TALKING, LIVING BREATHING THREAT
TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Sean: REALLY, SENATOR?
SAVE THE LECTURES.
HAVE YOU BEEN FAKING YOUR
BACKGROUND FOR DECADES!
AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT TRUE.
WALKING, TALKING, LEAVING
BREATHING EMBARRASSMENT.
THAT'S YOU TO THE PEOPLE OF
MASSACHUSETTS AND THE COUNTRY.
TWO OTHER SERIOUS EMBARRASSMENTS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
GILLIBRAND IS ON A QUEST TO END
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
SO NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE MORE POWER.
SO TOO IS BETO O'ROURKE.
COMPARED IT TO SLAVERY.
HE IS JUST ONE OF MANY RADICAL
DEMOCRATS RUNNING ON A PLATFORM
OF HOW DO WE GET MORE PEOPLE,
OF HOW DO WE GET MORE PEOPL --
POWER NOT JUST FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, BUT FOR THEM.
THE PEOPLE OF WASHINGTON, NEW
YORK, NEW JERSEY, ILLINOIS?
WILL THEY GET TO DECIDE EVERY
PRESIDENT?
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF STATES
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
POWER OVER YOUR WALLETS AND
BUSINESS AND OVER YOUR
HEALTHCARE AND PROPERTY RIGHTS
AND GUN RIGHTS.
POWER OVER YOUR LIFE.
DON'T BE FOOLED BY FALSE
PROMISES.
NOW GREEN DEALS.
NO OIL GAS, NO CARS AND NO COWS
AND NO PLANES.
EVERYTHING IS FREE.
THE FUTURE OF AMERICA IS AT
STAKE.
ONE MORE IMPORTANT BREAKING
STORY.
WE'LL ARE LEARNING ACCORDING TO
THE DAILY CALLER THAT GEORGE
SOROS PAID FIRMS TIED TO FUSION
GPS AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE
NEARLY $4 MILLION TO GROUPS.
THE OUTCOME IS THE SAME.
COLLUSION, LET'S SEE?